joining us right here uh prior to uh the
thanksgiving week
uh 12 in the national football league
courtesy of fedex is none other than
future hall of famer ann rodgers how you
doing aaron
good buddy and i just can't help but
listen to your intro there and wonder
yes uh who are those those shows that
you'd love to go against
who's the shows you hate the most okay
aaron um
now then should i give it should i give
an answer
like a professional a quarterback or
should i give an honest answer what
should i do
what do you think it's your world man
this is the peacock it's all brand new
whatever you want i'll just i'll just
say you know what aaron every show is
important you know
um i don't really like to give my uh
give my opponents anything
uh more than what they need to have i
just need to take care of my show take
it one segment at a time hope for the
best
um it is what it is and i'm only talking
about the guys who are here
i'm sorry when coach speak there my bad
how was that wow it was
that was impressively bad okay um
all right i want to beat cowherd in
rome's ass every single day is that
better
is that better yeah yeah there you go
my guys are clapping so they're they're
appreciative they're appreciative
yeah you know i circle this on my
calendar every single day
you know what i mean the rich eisen show
um
do you do that for bears a week aaron
i don't know about that i think i
definitely look at uh
when we're playing in chicago probably
the coldest i've been in my life
on a football field it's been in chicago
a couple times so
i always look and make sure that's the
first place i look uh when the schedule
does come out this year
as opposed to years past where we've
gotten kind of a reprieve by playing
them earlier in the season
um we have them towards the end so we
know that's going to be
nice and cold down chicago in week
16 17 yeah 17 that's right
that's week 17 could you could be game
256 potentially i don't know if that
really will be it but
you know um there's a lot of football
left to be played
this past weekend uh in
indianapolis what did you say to valdez
scantling after the game
aaron uh not a whole lot i mean
look he was disappointed he was uh you
know bummed out for sure
we've all been there before you know
it's it's uh
you know he didn't intentionally you
know try and turn the ball over there
uh i just reminded him how important he
was to
getting us in position to even send it
to overtime
and and just kind of hold on that
feeling i think a lot of times
uh with emotion we try and maybe run
from it too much or or
whatever and i think it's good to
embrace those times when we're
when we're emotional to really feel what
it feels like to uh
to have that disappointment and sit with
it and then after you've processed it to
move on and i think that's a part of
growth is processing those emotions
and then sitting with them
feeling them and then moving forward and
leaving those behind
and it just seems though that your team
is
still it's still clicking i i mean i i
look at you know
a game and obviously the result isn't
the way you were looking at it
but it does seem to me that you are
clicking offensively you've got tanyan
uh which i did not know rhymed with
funyun until he said pretty much the
same thing a few weeks ago
um but it seems to me that you you've
got uh a considerable championship team
in front of you
similar to to last year would you say
that this team
is in a better position than last year
or
just compare it if you wouldn't mind
from your perspective uh
to what we saw from a team last year
that was almost the one seed
yeah yeah we were a couple inches from
being the one seed
um you know it's interesting because i
feel like our teams are so different
even though the personnel is almost
exactly the same
okay um i just think that offensively
we've been helped by the second year in
the system and some growth from some
important players
um you know like robert tanyan not
tanyan yes we all learned
um elton jenkins who did a really nice
job at center force and corey went out
a couple days ago billy turner who's
moved from right guard to right tackle
and been very effective for us
lucas patrick who's moved in the
starting lineup and done a really really
good job
other than that it's a lot of the same
guys jamal williams i think came back
and has been a bigger
contributor for us especially in the
past game i was teasing with him all off
season about his beautiful
uh post on instagram where he was
running all over the field running like
you know 40 yard deep you know post
corners making these catches and stuff
but he showed up in incredible shape and
has been a big contributor
so i think the personnel is very similar
we've gotten jumps
from certain guys on offense then just
we've all felt a little more comfortable
in the system in year two
i think on defense there was a lot of
encouraging things on sunday
um from the energy i think though we
played with
forcing a couple turnovers it was a
little bit of a numb of the game across
the offense turned the ball over three
times and obviously we turned over on
special teams
but the second half especially the third
quarter went really uh poorly for us we
had six plays and then didn't really get
the ball back until eight minutes left
and fourth
um and put together a good drive and
then convert on fourth and one and then
had to
you know go 90 yards to uh to get to
overtime but
um i like our team a lot i like the
character of the team i think it's going
to be important
uh six games for us we got three those
are division games
and then we have a division leader uh in
philly
uh carolina and then obviously tennessee
who's been playing really
well this season so we're gonna find out
a lot about our team in the last six
weeks we usually do it's
weather gets cold um it's the
physicality of the game
really gets uh exposed or heightened or
highlighted
and uh it'll be interesting uh
interesting month and then a few minutes
left with aaron rodgers
here on the rich eisen show do you how
do you watch a monday night game like
last night
uh obviously i'm assuming you watch it
um
and and if so do you watch it like
you're watching film
are you watching the just the
quarterbacks you're watching
concepts what are you watching past pass
rush how do you watch a game like last
night
i didn't watch it come on now i didn't
see you one minute come on now you don't
that's
not another what are you doing on a
monday night instead
well uh i'm relaxing man i'm uh
enjoying uh enjoying my time reading a
good book
what are you reading um getting to bed
early it was it was a late night
uh sunday later night you know we got
back at 10 and we can never really fall
asleep after
the game whether it's an afternoon game
or a night game so um
so mondays and tuesdays are about
you know really getting my mind and body
back
so um you know if i want to get to bed
early on monday i usually uh
usually don't watch the game so that's
what happened last night so you there
was no curiosity factor
uh brady versus rams rams um
you know who maybe you see either one of
these teams you obviously have already
seen tampa but
no curiosity factor in watching a
football game at all
oh i mean i definitely i at one point i
think about 8 30 i checked the
you know i checked with the score was on
my phone but uh
but no i mean i'm sure i'll at some
point see this one on film and uh
get a chance to look at it what are you
reading then
what are you reading uh i'm i'm reading
a lot of books i'm reading a book uh
about the dream world right now about
dreaming it's called the history of
dreaming
so very interesting different cultures
about different cultures and how they
they uh
they look at the dream uh the dream one
um
you say why yeah why yeah what interests
you about
everything about the just the basic uh
lucidity of dreams
uh that that i often experience and and
uh
i think it's interesting to hear
perspectives about how ancient cultures
viewed it and
have present day uh uh smart people uh
look at uh
look at the dream wow so um do you
do you dream of football aaron and this
is a way for you to
decipher what you're seeing or other
stuff oh sometimes yeah definitely yeah
sometimes i've
uh have some of those type of dreams a
lot of times they're more nightmares
like
you know you have a dream where you uh
it's game day and you're not at the
stadium and you don't know why you're
not there and
you can't get there that's
uh that's a nightmare or you just you
don't have your pads or pants or
whatever it might be and you're going
out in the field uh that that's
definitely happened before or you know
you have
some weird dream where you're uh playing
in a different uniform and it's very
confusing and
different coaches and you don't you know
who are you playing for your
packers and you don't recognize anybody
on the team
yeah those are interesting this is
amazing so
how do you uh and then we'll get to
fedex uh how do you decipher that
i love this this is amazing i could talk
about this literally for the next two
hours but
i mean yeah i mean i don't know i think
the the the better ones
you know the more decipherable ones or
maybe where you
um you're in situations whether past
um or presence
that happens i mean the beauty about
dreams is a lot of times
you might be talking to someone or
thinking about someone
uh that maybe having you know childhood
friends or something and then
you have a dream and they're in the
dream like that those are always fun
fun ones to try and decipher where you
you had a conversation about uh
you know hiking to a waterfall and then
the dream is all about you know that
experience right i just i find that i
find the dream well very fast
i always have a dream that i always have
a dream that i have not studied for a
test i'm back in college i'm
about to fail this test and everything
that's happened in my life since then is
not going to be
because of it literally and i wake up
that's a recurring dream of mine
and i didn't think i'd share anything
like that with you today but you brought
it up so
that's it see you never know where it's
going to go buddy you never know
it's really it's like a trip no doubt um
now i know where it's going to go
because i want to make sure that we
uh we talk about the ship-a-thon that
fedex has
been kind enough to uh give him this
phone call chat with you
to this show uh what is the fedex
ship-a-thon that's going down
the ship-a-thon is what we're calling uh
is what fedex is uh
is calling basically this holiday season
just because it's gonna be so many
people
probably more than usual with uh
obviously the covet and all this you
know there's gonna be a lot more
shipping going on
so uh you know we connected and
um uh like i was teasing my lineman
there's been a few years
not every gift but there's been maybe
some of the bigger gifts to some of the
guys that might not have been
delivered uh on christmas or even maybe
a month or a couple months afterwards
um so this year as opposed to years past
uh you know i shopped early and thanks
to fedex we shipped it early and they
got their presents even before
thanksgiving which i know was surprising
to them so
i'm really thankful to fedex for uh for
helping out with that and the
ship-a-thon is just
hey you know this is just a good
reminder i think for everybody it's
going to be super busy
so get your get your stuff uh shipped as
soon as possible
for my linemen you know i'm thankful
what'd you get to get them
the traeger grills and then a nice white
glove tailor-made
uh golf club experience which would be
great for the few the golf and i must
admit
it is almost like uh an event
uh going golfing with those guys and you
never know what's gonna happen
okay and that's fedex.com holiday guide
uh
now i need to figure out what i'm
getting the guys here at the rich eisen
show because you just kind of
set the bar very high although aaron um
i
again i didn't think i'd be bringing
this up to you uh
i found out that the guys here on this
show all ordered lou malnati's pizza
from chicago
uh and didn't include me uh and i found
that out on live television radio last
week
and it did mess with the team chemistry
i'm not gonna lie how
how would you as the ceo i guess of your
offense handle such a thing like that
aaron
this is no dream either this happened
well publicly shaming them would be
probably the first way to go about it
um that's always that's always
a good route there and then uh with a
pro bowl quarterback
right where the pro with a championship
mvp pro bowl quarterback
use used in enlist him in that process
as well
yeah definitely a restriction of
privileges for sure okay
um and then and then probably a public
apology
on uh across multiple uh social media
platforms okay
yeah which already took place last week
that did take place yes
actually the way that they trolled me
aaron is that they did
after me bitching about it bring in the
pizzas and lay it on my
desk like uh the notre dame team laid
their jerseys on the desk
in rudy which is the movie i hate the
most because i'm a michigan guy
so they actually trolled me in trying to
make amends
it just doesn't stop wait let me just
let me just make you feel better because
uh that was one of my favorite movies
growing up and i've since learned
from a former coach of mine who played a
notre dame that that never happened
there's many parts of that movie that
never actually happened like vince
vaughn throwing the half back pass to
give
rudy a chance to run down and kick off
never happened fake
what else please keep going this does
make me feel much better i have no idea
how much this makes me feel better
anything else anything else that you
know that's false
yeah i don't think john favreau actually
married that girl
[Laughter]
he left her for somebody uh a little
better looking i think okay and the guy
who played rock wasn't slow clapping
outside either he wasn't doing that slow
clap okay very good
this is good yeah that never happened
either thank you aaron you have made me
feel better and i appreciate the call
have a great thanksgiving holiday and uh
let's chat down the road
always enjoy our chats look forward to
buddy maybe maybe we'll talk about
uh game of thrones and uh and the
offshoot coming out
with uh starring oregon okay are you
going to be in that you already got a
role in that that everyone in the
everyone in uh uh the twitterverse is
gonna
inaccurately describe as your role
you're gonna have something like that i
mean i sent in
yeah i sent in my my reel from the
office uh
just to remind them that i can actually
act a little bit so hopefully
that might give me uh give me some
serious time okay
in the meantime uh uh you've got the
chicago bears in front of you so good
luck with that and we'll chat down the
line thanks again aaron
always appreciate it brother thank you
you got it that's aaron rodgers that
aaron rodgers 12.
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here